a Florida woman accused of shooting and
killing her neighbor through the front
door is expected in court Susan Lawrence
charged in the death of AJ Owens what
happened is Jones knocks down Lowrance
door following a dispute involving her
kids Mark Strassman has more
his words was Grandma Grandma I couldn't
save her Pamela Diaz says her 12 year
old grandson feels guilty he wasn't able
to save his mother AJ Owens how do you
explain this loss you can't because I
still can't believe that this happened
when
does a person get shot
for knocking on a door last Friday
owens's children were playing in a field
near Susan lorenza's Ocala Florida home
police say Lorenz became angry she
yelled and threw a roller skate at them
when Owens knocked on Lawrence's door
looking for answers Lorenz fired a
gunshot through the door hitting Owens
in the chest
community and family members are Furious
Lorenz wasn't arrested right away Lorenz
claims self-defense and police say the
four-day delay in her arrest was because
of Florida's stand your ground law it
allows deadly force if someone believes
they're in imminent danger for every
hour that passed until there was an
arrest
it was sending the message that it was
allowable
to shoot black people who knock on the
door police say since January 2021
they've responded to at least a half
dozen calls to what they described as
feuding between Owens and Lorenz Diaz
says she will now raise her four young
grandchildren but I have to be strong
yeah I have no choice to raise these
children to give them a future that
their mother would have wanted to if
convicted Lorenz could face 30 years
behind bars for CBS mornings Mark
Strassman in Ocala Florida